when it comes to michael saylor i guess
there's two things that i'd be
interested to see i'm curious your
opinion on which is like
one
most people i think within kind of the
bitcoin in general crypto community
expect bitcoin's price to appreciate uh
pretty rapidly here over the next six to
12 months etc and go over 100 whatever
it might be uh the the price prediction
that most people have in mind but then
at some point before the next having
we're going to enter into a bear market
i think most people expect right and is
that something where you see uh michael
saylor just continues to acquire bitcoin
regardless of the price or is that
something where you think that one he'll
get kind of [ __ ] for right people will
start giving him a hard time or do you
think he kind of holds off and waits for
the opportune time to do it he's buying
bitcoin his aggregate price now is 29
000 i think we just said so it's still
at a very low kind of cost basis
relative to where most people think this
is headed do you think that he continues
to buy as we get up over 100 150 200 et
cetera
uh i have no inside information etc uh
but given what he's publicly said uh
what he's tweeted his perspective how
he's spending his time energy uh what
appears to be his focus i don't think
that he stops buying bitcoin now what i
do think is going to become very
interesting is uh if you're taking on
debt
to buy an asset like this uh the terms
and the structure of the debt is really
important right you could see a world
where if he took on a bunch of debt and
he couldn't cover the payments and then
the price fell
now all of a sudden he can get
liquidated
really bad situation
the other thing is
a company cannot mark
the appreciation of the assets on their
balance sheet
but they have to mark the depreciation
or the loss of value so for example
let's say he spent three billion dollars
on bitcoin and bitcoin's price fell
below that 26 27 000 purchase price he
would have to mark a loss
well if it's a big enough loss given the
equity value
he could be bankrupt
right now he's got the assets on his
balance sheet nothing changes the price
of the assets had changed what he can't
do is he can't mark up the assets right
in terms of uh that value of accrual uh
so we got to change the
accounting and kind of tax treatment and
all that stuff we got to change those
rules just from a reporting standpoint
and the reason why i bring up the
borrowing is because you also have to be
very careful let's say that you went you
borrowed 10 billion dollars and bitcoin
was at 100k
and then all of a sudden bitcoin crashed
50 percent
you aren't being responsible with
leverage right it's no different than a
retail trader so i think what's really
interesting about what michael's been
doing is he's actually not taken on
incredible levels of debt compared to
the value of his business compared to
the balance sheet etc and you have to
remember this is somebody who is one of
the longest standing ceos of a publicly
traded company he understands capital
markets better than most and i think
that uh he will continue to buy bitcoin
but i wouldn't be surprised uh and again
this is my opinion as the price of
bitcoin goes up he'll use less and less
debt to do it and he'll start to
actually just try to drive cash flow and
use that so that he doesn't get caught
in a situation in case there is a blow
off top and a market correction which
there has been historically he won't get
caught basically uh with high levels of
debt in the asset that is uh contracting
his balance sheet because you could get
in some really weird situations if that
was to occur yeah so essentially the the
play right now is he's using leverage
through debt to be able to go buy
bitcoin just on the assumption that the
the bitcoin is going to appreciate at a
faster rate than the debt is that he's
gonna have to pay on right so if you get
to a point where bitcoin's at 100 150
200 250 and then we see a massive
drawdown that deck could get called and
he may get liquidated on some of this
position now the reason why i say
structure is so important again i
haven't looked at all of the the nuances
of the structure but my understanding is
in a couple of these tranches have been
unsecured uh and also he can convert
them right so uh what that basically
means in super over generalized terms is
uh he's not necessarily borrowing
securing it against the business and
then also too is he has the opportunity
to either pay back or he can take that
debt and convert it to equity on his
business so you almost have a situation
where it could be super dilutive
but you're not gonna get in a situation
where you basically can't
pay the debt right and so you have to
remember he has a software cash flowing
business that he's able to leverage as
well so it's not just about his balance
sheet it's also about the cash flow
which ends up being a pretty unique
strategy and you know look we've seen
tesla square others go out and actually
buy bitcoin put on their balance sheet
we have yet to see any of them go and
and kind of uh leverage this speculative
attack or this borrow and buy strategy
uh but in terms of um
you know kind of
what the expectation is moving forward
somebody else is definitely going to do
it i mean a guy's got a 7 billion
business why would somebody else not say
that's a great idea and go do it too
it's just who is that company going to
be nobody knows how are they going to
execute nobody knows yet right but my
expectation is that somebody will end up
doing well it becomes harder to do when
bitcoin's at 100 150 200 right well it
becomes easier in terms of if you bought
some bitcoin at a lower price and now
your balance sheets higher you can
actually borrow against it and be less
you know on an ltv basis uh but it's
it's riskier in terms of if the price
falls over time and then you're
basically you know let's say that use
these examples let's say you get 100 of
bitcoin uh and you took a 50 loan
against it right 50 ltv and all of a
sudden bitcoin falls fifty percent ko
you're done yeah right so what do you
have to do if you suck if you use the
bitcoin as the as what secured it
against the against the uh bitcoin so
what ends up happening is they're not
using the bitcoin as the actual
collateral to borrow in many cases it's
actually um either the business is
securing it or it's an unsecured loan so
there's a lot of different things that
kind of play into it and you know maybe
we can get somebody who's like a credit
or
a lending expert to come on and kind of
talk through the nuances of this but the
structure really really really matters
when you're doing it with this size with
an asset this volatile and you're
essentially saying uh publicly i have a
business strategy
and i have a treasury strategy and the
treasury strategy is what everyone's
focusing on but you can't lose sight of
the fact that they still have a business
and they're one of the leaders in
business intelligence where is he doing
this where is he buying the actual
bitcoin do you know
uh i don't know um my guess is that
i think coinbase came out and publicly
said that uh they're the ones that are
buying it but he's using one of these
one of these known like um yeah he's not
buying it himself okay i'm curious
because he's not calling up somebody on
an otc desk and being like hey uh this
michael sayler from microstrategy uh
would you like to uh sell me some
bitcoin what's up guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]